[Music]
everybody's gone look honey this summer
is gonna be great you're gonna make
friends there's nothing to worry about
welcome to the rim of the world and
venture camp Alex I'm your leader Logan
enough huh
and dad where are you going I don't
think we should wander this far maybe we
should head back
follow me it was that
ever seen anything like them
I didn't finish day it's Joan Gabriel
you need to wait here until the adults
realized they loved us
you see the size of that we need to find
our parents we got to get to the seat do
not move
we're war you're not safe here
you've gotta go we can't leave you okay
Sonia now this is a crypto key I can
activate our satellite defense we should
try to find JPL
it's a NASA facility 70 miles away from
here how are we supposed to go 70 miles
1973 Ford Mustang Mach 1 I can't drive a
stick
just
we have each other
and we can't give up now I'm your master
now No
the line is now I am the master okay we
really need to get you a girl
and I propose a toast oh crap this is
from 1969 could please get some fresh
wine off it's gonna be my first time
right
[Music]